الخامسه والنصف صباحا بالتوقيت المحلي كان
شارع ملتا حيث اقف الان مسرحا لجريمه
مروعه حيث قام شخص يستقل حافله صغيره بدهس
عده اشخاص نقل ثلاثه منهم للمستشفى
لكن مدينه التي تبعد 130 ميلا شمال غربي
لندن كانت مسرحا لعمليه الطعن الساعه
الرابعه فجرا في شارع الكستن الذي يبعد
كيلومترين فقط عن هنا بعد ذلك اصبح شارع
مجدله مسرحا لجريمه اخرى حيث وجدت جثه في
الشارع
انا على بعد 25 ثانيه مشيا عن المكان الذي
وقعت فيه احدى الجرائم اشعر بحجم تغطيه
الاعلاميه والرجال الشرطه الامر كان مرعبا
بالنسبه الي
انه لامر مروع حقا لست في
امان صدمه كبيره
لما سن ناتي الى وسط المدينه ولم نفهم ما
حدث حتى الان
ثلاثه قتلى وثلاثه جرحى ومعتقل لدى شرطه
عمره 31 عاما محصله صباح جنوني شهدت فيه
ثلاثه حوادث امنيه متزامنه الطوق الامني
هذا حصر سته شوارع على الاقل واوقف خدمه
ترامب لساعات طويله
الشرطه المحليه ووحده مكافحه الارهاب
وقوات امنيه مسلحه ومقنعه في مشهد قل
نظيره في شوارع بريطانيا احتلت شوارع
مدينه ناطنينغام لساعات طويله اضافه الى
عشرات من سيارات الطوارئ والاطفاء كل
التفصيل مهم في هذه التحقيقات الضخمه من
كاميرات المراقبه في الشوارع الى استجواب
المعتقل حتى مداهمات عده نفذتها الشرطه
المحليه فيما حبست المدينه انفسها خوفا من
هجمه اخرى من مسرح الجريمه في مصطفى زارو
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات